hello everyone and welcome to another
great day from the second day of the
quarterfinals in a match between lebanon
and magnus carlson magnus won
uh the first day really really easily i
would say not easily but
the score would suggest it wasn't all
that difficult for him he won two games
and drew one
uh which makes it the game over as four
games are being played and you only need
two and a half points to win the match
uh but this is something that happens in
pretty much every tournament magnus
crushes the first day and then he gets
into a lot of trouble in the second day
so
very interesting uh to see what will
happen here
and also i would just like to mention uh
after this video i will
have a very short announcement and also
a very fun
story that includes the mailman so if
any you are interested in that
you know uh there will be more content
after the actual game
uh so eleven with the white pieces opens
with e4
magnus replies with e5 we have knight to
f3
uh knight to c6 and bishop to b5 going
for the rue lopez defense
uh we have uh for the royal lopez
opening uh we have a6 morphy's defense
pushing back the bishop and now bishop
to a4 and this is something that's
been played a million times uh knight to
f6 we have castles and the bishop to c5
now nicely developing the so-called the
arkhangelsk
variation or the new york angles or the
molar variation
it bears many names uh we have c3
preparing to strike in the center and
the magnus castles here we have b4
now striking in the center and bishop
back to a7 and now that the bishop is no
longer able to
go back to e7 it does make sense to pin
this knight so bishop to g5
pinning the knight and now uh there are
a couple of moves that
were played in this position the most
common idea is just h6 we want to chase
away that bishop or maybe even for even
force white
to capture here another idea is first uh
playing b5 just
throwing in a nice tuition suit or
there's even a knight the e7
there is only one game in the database
with knight e7 it was played
uh in a game between balashov and
grishok that um
agarishuk was able to win very nicely uh
but
here we have e captus on b4 by magnus
and now it is only as of move uh
eight that we have a completely new game
so let's see what's carlson's idea
as uh lemon's next move does not come as
a surprise 11 pushes e5
and it makes sense the knight is pinned
eleven attacks it so what do you play
here
of course h6 this is a very common theme
we have bishop to h4 and now g5 chasing
away the bishop even further and here
there are some lines where you can
actually sacrifice a piece here with
captures captures it captures but this
is not one of them
because at the end of this line knight
captures an e5 and you don't really have
a good compensation for the sacrificed
piece
so instead 11 tries to bishop captures
on c6
first we have d captures in c6 and only
now knight captures on g5
and now while it would be uh possible
for magnus to capture the knight for
example captures and captures spinning
the knight now d
captures in c3 offering a queen trade
here 11 would just trade queens very
happily captures captures and now the
knight cannot move
because the rook would be hanging there
so just knight captures on c3
uh one wait again the game could
continue and after bishop to e6 for
example he captures an f6 and we get
this position where white is up upon
but magnus would have the bishop's pair
and in an open game
it's uh comet's compensation enough for
for uh
being down upon so instead after knight
uh captures on g5 we have d
captures on c3 by magnus now 11 trades
queens as in the previous line
captures captures knight captures on c3
uh but now
not trading uh pieces but rather going
for knight to d5
and now what do you play here uh well
here 11 went for as his knight is still
under attack he moved it with knight to
g to e4 but
there was the very interesting knight
captures on f7 now there's a double
attack on the rook
and you can't really capture the knight
but the problem is after rook to e8 it's
hard to find the move here for white
because if knight captures here just
king h7 and the knight has no squares
the bishop covers f5 and
g4 so the knight is kind of trapped you
have to defend it with bishop to g5 or
something like that
but then uh then we could get a lot of
uh
well different moves for example rook
captures attacks the bishop bishop gets
defended with h4
and so on let's say captures captures
and again we get this position where
white is up upon but black has the
bishop pair a little uh
better development it would be it would
be pretty crazy but the white would
definitely
have some some some chances here so
instead after knight d5 11 doesn't go
for knight captures on f7 instead he
goes back knight g
to e4 and now magnus trades knight
captures with b
captures and rook to d3 now paralyzing
the knight as
the c3 pawn would would be captured so
rook
eight to d1 offering a rook trade and
magnus trades with captures captures and
bishop to e6 now preparing to bring the
rook into the game
we have a3 as the pawn on a2 is under
attack so
11 defends it we have a3 and now now
magnus doesn't want to face
knight to f6 knight to f6 if the if this
knight comes to f6 is just going to be
an overwhelming position to
defend because it's just super ugly you
you put that knight to f6 you can maybe
play some rook d3 rook g3 moves it's uh
going to be pretty
pretty pretty hard to play this so
magnus plays this very very instructive
pawn sacrifice
f5 and he allows e captures an f6 alpha
song
which 11 goes for there really isn't
nothing better he captures an f6
and now only now rook to e8
so bringing the rook into the game uh we
have h3
and now bishop back to b3 attacking the
rook and opening up a discovery towards
this knight so here only now 11 goes
f7 with check gives back the pawn
king captures and now rook the d7 with
check saving
both the rook and the knight we have
came to g6 not allowing any more checks
and now as the knight is hanging you
have to move it knight back to d2 with
an attack on the bishop here
so rook the e one with check makes sense
as the
bishop pair is almost fully operational
uh king the h1
and now the excellent bishop the e6
magnus tries to trick levin into
capturing on c7 so he can get bishop to
b810 and
the rook and the rook is
is a goner as it's pinned you can you
can't move it
so instead after bishop to e6 we have
rook to d8
11 sees that of course he cannot capture
on c7 and
now rook to e2 attacking the knight and
with a double attack on the f2 pawn
so knight f3 and magnus just grabs it we
have bishop captures on f2
uh bishop captures rook captures and
king to g3 now chasing away
carlson's rook rook to c2 going after
the c2 pawn and now
rook to d3 defending but now that's uh
that's a very passive square for the
rook we have bishop to d5
paralyzing white's position even further
the knight now cannot move as then you
lose the g2 pawn with
check so eleven tries uh tries a very
nice trick
knight uh king to f4 now hoping for rook
captures because then you just pick up
the bishop
rook capture spawn captures and knights
the h for check
and that's just it uh king has to move
you pick up the the rook you're up a
piece
you're gonna win this game uh magnus of
course sees this so he sidesteps
any future checks king to f6 and now g4
so if levin can get a nice pass pawn h4
g5 and then maybe he can still fight as
he
is down upon but magnus of course will
try to prevent this
rook to f2 uh definitely uh
the the right idea with h4
now preparing to create a pass pawn and
the b5 magnus also starts pushing his
pawns on the queen side
and here 11 uh doesn't really have an
active move
the rook needs to defend the knight the
knight cannot move because it's pinned
so king the g3 trying to chase away the
rook uh but now
of course you know what's happening here
feel free to pause the video and
win the game for magnus in the simplest
possible way
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on being a true
master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
a rook
captures an f3 just trade everything off
and that's it uh it doesn't really
matter you you could also capture with
uh
no you can't you have to capture with
czech so rook captures
uh rook captures on f3 bishop captures
king captures
and now there is nothing more to be done
here uh but
um uh yeah uh
although i don't uh yeah okay they still
continue playing although this is uh
of course it is uh known that this is
winning for for black black is up upon
uh the problem is uh magnus played c5
with king the e4 11
tries to contest the position but now
just c6 taking away all of the squares
from the white king
uh king back to f4 and now a5 by magnus
preparing b4 which will create a past
pawn so here
king back to e4 and now even a4 because
when you push this and a captures you
want to have this
pawn as fast as possible so here king d3
but now king to a5 king to e5 eleven
again gains opposition king e3 but now
b4
and there is nothing much to be done
here uh problem is if you capture
then we already said for example
captures captures captures and then a3
the pawn cannot be stopped the king is
too far away and
if you don't if you play something else
for example after b4 like levan did he
played king to d2 but now magnus just
played b3
that's not a b3 uh magnus just played b3
and it was in this position animal 42
that eleven are resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done uh
this is a pass pawn white king
is stuck here guarding it because
otherwise he's going to become a queen
and magnus will use this time to collect
these pawns promote this pawn or you
know use uh
any other way of winning this game
because there are plenty
uh so yeah a really really awesome game
eleven tried it was a really really
brutal
uh the there could they could have gone
you know a lot of different ways they
could have gone for eleven could
have gone for that knight captures an f7
idea which was a lot of fun
but you know it would best play of
course it would not be enough to grab a
full point both of them notice as this
has been
fairly fairly analyzed throughout the
years
so really a wild game magnus won the
second day as well so this game ended
with a result
not oh every game ended with a result i
meant with a
decisive result magnus won the first
game in the the next two games ended in
a draw so magnus wins
both the first and the second day and uh
proceeds to the to the semi-finals and
if you guys are interested in some
uh other pairings as well here they are
so let's just check that out
uh so yeah magnus defeat eleven uh and
will face yanni ponnichi in the
semifinals and
uh wesley so defeated furuja maksim the
uh
lost to anishigiri so we will have uh uh
wesley silver sunish giri the other pair
of the semifinals
and then we're gonna see who will uh be
in the finals but
by the looks of it you know objectively
i guess it would be another magnus
versus wesley final but you never know
uh you know that's why we're here and uh
you know anything can happen
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and
now for the story that i promised you or
rather first the a
short announcement uh a long long time
ago like maybe six months ago i created
a telegram
page called the bar in the library and i
invited some people over
but you know there was a lot of spam in
it and people didn't really follow any
rules and they didn't have any uh
admins or moderators um uh so i decided
not to advertise it anymore
uh but today i uh you know kind of
revived it i added three
new administrators maybe we can add some
more if if needed
uh so you guys are welcome to join uh
you know for the moment we we're not
having any serious discussions during
anything is just a nice
place for you to visit like a virtual
bar in the library you know
it could be a lot of fun uh so there's
that the first link in the description
below if you guys are interested and
also
now the story regarding the mailman now
this morning uh as we woke up we uh
yellen and myself went to get a cup of
coffee
and we were the only ones there of
course you cannot go into bars but you
can
drink the coffee outside and we were the
only ones there having some coffee and
then this mailman arrived but i did not
recognize this mailman as he has a
different route than all the other
mailmen that i know
so we started uh you know conversing uh
as you know that's what what you do when
you when you see a mailman
and we talked about a lot of stuff we
talked about you know how
the uh well how the mail gets from one
place to another the history
of uh you know male uh then as you know
some potential
future scenarios or what will happen to
male delivery and you know uh well
we discussed a lot a lot of things don't
want to bore you with that
uh but i asked him what was like his uh
most memorable
experience while delivering mail and he
said that
okay there was one very uh negative
experience it
involved you know a dog and some blood
but there was also a very positive
experience
uh he said that he was delivering a mail
to this you know backwards
village like the the snow was really
really
uh you know deep uh it was like uh uh
you know even above his uh
uh above his knees and he was he said he
was freezing it was like minus
minus 23 celsius or something it was
maybe some 30 35 years ago or something
like that
and he said that he he was so cold he
was so sad he thought he he wasn't
he wasn't going to make it uh you know i
mean i don't mean that he would die but
he
that he wouldn't be able to deliver the
mail but he was able to deliver the mail
and it was this really
uh you know house that was you know
really really
deep into the village and it was a
really old house he said
the the people were were like extremely
poor uh they had the house was made of
stone and of mud
and that he was like i mean wow
that's uh you know uh he he couldn't
believe that people
uh still live in in those kinds of
conditions
uh and um when he knocked and you know
offered them their mail they invited him
in and
he said that they warmed him up and they
gave him
uh some food and it was the best food
that he ever had he said that he had
like uh
a goose uh with some with some cabbage
with some sweet cabbage and it was a it
was a smoked
goose uh i don't know i've never had
that
but like yeah like smoked smoked goose
with some cabbage
and um he said that he drank like half a
liter of red wine
and that he was so happy and that even
though you know the journey of getting
there was
really really harsh uh you know the the
overall experience you know
uh was great and kind of restored his uh
faith uh in
humanity because he said those people
didn't really have anything but
they still uh you know uh handed him the
the leftovers of of the smoked
goose uh sure really really awesome
and you know uh whenever whenever you uh
you know encounter a mailman and your
mail is safely delivered to you you
should always you know
award them in any way you can uh because
you know without people delivering stuff
properly we we
could go back to the dark ages so i just
wanted to share that with you as it was
it was quite a
quite uh quite a coffee i had this
morning uh so yeah once again
that's the game and the story and the
announcement hope you guys enjoyed that
uh i would like to thank
klaus muller nielsen uh robert kiefer uh
congratulations luca
vollenman uh for matching uh
chessboost.com and gregory rossolimo for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing with
the coverage of the semi-finals checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day